pardon madame est ce que vous auriez dit
francs pour payer le café
quoi pardon monsieur est ce que vous
auriez s'il vous plaît 10 francs pour
régler mon café vous allez auriez vous
s'il vous plaît la modique somme de 10
francs donc j'aime acquis de cette
excitante
dix balles vous avez pas dit souvent un
bal pour payer le café
écoutez comme suit une bonne foi que
vous donnez du jeu mais vraiment c'est
cette fois une bonne idée de venir
prendre un café à chambéry
oui bon ça dans la mesure où
c'est moins prestigieux
il ya moins de blaireaux pour payer la
moitié ailleurs
fortement et merci madame vous avez
d'éteindre les tickets de métro j'ai du
courrier à faire et je dois faire des
coups
on a buzzé pas madame alors bon d'accord
merci madame donnez-moi - 10 balles
évidemment je suis gonflé mais gagner
plein de cogneau vous êtes paco rabanne
ou vous êtes bourrés doublé alors j'ai
décroché un peu de pognon vraiment 20
balles à votre jeu n'est pas boire de
café cher beau petit ses déboires drake
a pris 1,51 blaireau pour le payer
merci monsieur à merci excusez moi je me
suis trompé ses 23 ans excusez moi
autant pour moi ah non je ne partais pas
sans payer
et à 20 points gap mondes différents
vienna monnaie vous et que les bars on
ne soyez sympa donnez-moi dit prêt à
dépanner mois
et coûté très franchement c'est la
première fois je vous demande quelque
chose ok je vous ai jamais rien demandé
avant
non mais moi je faisais jamais rien
demandé avant alors pour une fois
pour une fois que mon un service vous
êtes vraiment pas sympa à mon avis vous
êtes plein degrés et les bijoux en or
vous acteurs
chichis
bon bon écoutez j'ai pas le temps payé
mon café qu'on en finisse et maintenant
non plus
vous êtes le doublé c'est une double et
vous auriez simplement différent pour
laquelle café il me manque des points
merci vous êtes bien gentil monsieur
gentil attendent étonné je vois vous
avez autant de l'abonné mettez le tout
payé tout ça m'arrange deux pièces de 10
francs
merci monsieur
merci
c'est bien gentil monsieur merci je vais
régler comme ça
merci monsieur
non
non vous montrer le cap et monsieur baou
merci bonne gaule
pardon
la monnaie vous montrer le cap et cette
fois ça passe est maintenant qui avoue
je remercie infiniment mieux êtes bon
j'ai tout le monde était comme vous
monsieur en parlait mais c'est tout le
monde était comme vous merci messieurs
salles imax
ça va tu va régler mon café et a bon
coeur toi et l'accord verbal max a bon
coeur
et est parce que j mende bivalves
medieval match quel [ __ ] notre menu
valaisan foireux pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu